i couldn't beat dexter morgan anymore he
was cursed
and i wasn't going to pass that curse
down to harrison
hey guys pete here this will be my
breakdown of dexter new blood episode 6.
we passed the mid-season we're moving
towards the conclusion and things are
starting to fall into place there were
some big reveals insight into character
motivations and the big bad showdown is
starting to shape up i'm going to recap
everything that happened and talk about
what it might mean about where things
are going right after this quick spoiler
warning if you haven't watched too many
tuna sandwiches episode 6 of new blood
then this video might not be for you and
with that out of the way let's get into
it
the sixth episode opens bright and early
the morning after episode five's ending
harrison is chopping wood and feeding
the animals before dexter wakes up he
thinks this is about him making a good
decision to send him to therapy but it's
really because of what kurt told him
about doing something kind for someone
when you're pissed off at them this is
an interesting point in his continuing
to misinterpret things about his son
because of their situation debba echoes
the idea that he's doing the right thing
as opposed to what his father harry did
with him he finds the job application
and isn't sure about how he feels about
harrison going to work for the father of
his latest victim when they argue about
it he tries to frame it in a different
way but it all just serves to make the
teenager more committed to taking the
job he reveals that he didn't go to the
therapy session that instead he talked
to kurt and it was his idea to do his
chores and this leaves dext wondering
why is kirk caldwell suddenly so
interested in my son it's a good
question and one we don't get the answer
to right away but what we do get is a
little more insight into how much of a
freak kurt actually is he's trying to
make a sort of mask to cover chloe's
gunshot wound and when it's not to his
liking he breaks down and starts
punching the corpse lamenting what a
waste and the situation has him wound up
later we see that he's pretty desperate
outside the truck stop and he notices a
new girl he rushes over to make an
introduction he ends up giving her
hundreds of dollars and tries to move
things along so he can get her into his
truck and out to the cabin only she's
traveling with her boyfriend who comes
back to tell her that they have a ride
and they take off together and kurt
looks pretty pissed then harrison comes
up talking about the job telling him
that his dad's not all right with it and
won't sign the paper but he wants to do
it anyway and kurt doesn't seem to care
says he can have the job he signs it
himself and the wrestling match is
brought up before they cut away on his
way into town angela pulls dexter over
and shows him the obituary she's clearly
upset dexter's taken by surprise and she
tells him to drive directly to the
station and she'll follow to make sure
that he doesn't try to run away it's a
tense setup it's the moment he's been
fearing and she rightly starts by
pointing out that he's been lying to her
since they first met he does a good job
of delivering his lie he dramatically
tells her that he was running from all
of the death first his wife was murdered
and then his sister so he drove his boat
into the hurricane expecting to die but
when he lived he thought he deserved
another chance it all adds up taking
extreme measures for sure but all in
response to this trauma that he went
through and the character does his best
to get it to come across as sincere with
a hint that he's watching how it's
landing and how she's reacting to guide
where he goes it's probably the best
crafted scene the show has put together
since the early ones with harrison and
the two performances here really sell it
we follow her facial expressions while
angela takes it all in and even though
it appears that she accepts that he
might be telling her the truth she's not
ready to move past it she says that all
she knows is relationships are built on
trust and how can she ever trust him
again and i really liked how when she
was pushing back in relation to harrison
that she kept trying to refocus things
back to dexter because he kept
deflecting and we'll see that happen
again when he's in the therapist office
later so it was a really interesting
scene we'll come back and talk about it
some more later she's just not
interested in talking with him anymore
at that time and needs some space to
sort of wrap her head around what's
going on and how she feels about it
after he goes molly comes in and she
wants to work with angela to figure out
what's going on with kurt and she tells
her to stay away from him she doesn't
want to spook a suspect before she has a
chance to build a case molly
half-heartedly agrees to stay away but
it doesn't seem like she's going to
actually do that ever since angela
pulled him over he's been trying to
figure out how she found out who he
really is since she just spent the
weekend away with a true crime podcaster
molly becomes his main suspect and while
he's at work he decides to look into her
he listens to the bay harbor butcher
episode of her podcast as she's
describing things we hear him say ah the
good old days and more importantly that
she's skeptical that dokes actually did
it she says that she tracked someone
down on reddit from special ops and that
he said that dokes was out of town when
some of the killings happened so there
was no way he could be the killer
something to keep in mind for later to
be sure harrison is becoming a bit of a
legend around school and audrey asks him
out he's into it but then he gets a text
from dexter saying they're going to
therapy together it appears that he's
taking angela's advice while at the same
time making sure that harrison follows
through dexter just sort of fumbles
around until harrison lays out
everything that happened with rita
hannah and how he learned that his
father abandoned him the therapist isn't
impressed with it was a tough time for
everyone and says he'll have to dig
deeper for the sessions to work when
asked to talk about his past dexter
isn't able to say anything meaningful
despite this being the perfect
opportunity for him to do so and he
manages to derail the whole thing when
he says that his marriage to rita sort
of fell apart his son points out that
his mother was murdered by a serial
killer and dex quickly says well you
know he was so young you don't remember
anything and we learned that he just
knows about the messed up stuff he's
read online as it continues it becomes
apparent that dexter won't go into
what's really going on with him and
harrison feels abandoned all over again
in the session after he tries to make
dinner at home and is left eating by
himself he thinks about molly again and
decides to call logan to try to get more
information from him when they meet he
ends up more concerned about the
situation because he finds out that they
aren't together anymore and with matt
not being dead why is she still in iron
lake angela is trying to put together
what kurt might be hiding and decides to
go search the caves when she realizes
that kurt wanted the search to go on
right up until he didn't when he heard
that they were gonna search them
harrison comes over to see audrey he
tells her that he's so angry and that he
thinks about hurting people he brings up
ethan which she says is different
because he had to he saved them but he
tells her that it wasn't the first time
he did something like that just recently
on the way there from florida someone
tried to touch him while he was sleeping
and again she's quick to say that that
was justified too then he admits that he
thinks about hurting everyone all the
time her backstory has so many
similarities to his with her mom leaving
and her dad dying after he married
angela that she gets it they both feel
like they don't fit anywhere and they're
on the outside looking in and they agree
that that can mess you up they have a
connection and they hook up and when
they lay back on the bed you can see
that harrison has the straight razor in
his back pocket the next morning angela
finds him in audrey's bed and drives him
home it's another thing to point out how
dex lacks even the basic parental
instincts not knowing what to do about
it he shifts his focus on molly instead
things take an interesting turn there
when he runs into her talking to kurt at
the tavern he plugs in his phone using
the charger at the bar and records their
conversation he then follows them when
he sees them leaving and listens to what
they were saying kurt admits that he
lied about the facetime and claims that
matt is hiding out at his cabin he
offers to let molly interview him if she
doesn't tell anyone where she's going so
he's luring her to the middle of nowhere
with no one knowing where she's at and
as he approaches dexter notices a very
serious serial killer vibe about the
whole situation he sees them going
through the basement and he has a moment
there where he thinks that he could just
let her die and then she would be out of
his hair for good but decides that he
should intervene instead
while they're in the hallway on the way
to the room molly is starting to get
freaked out and just in time dex opens
the storm door kurt is surprised but has
to pretend and gets even more upset when
dexter forces his way in to get a look
at the room he's able to get molly out
of there she now thinks he's a good guy
and he now knows that kurt is the serial
killer that angela has been looking for
she's at the caves with teddy searching
while everyone else is at the wrestling
match things get crazy there when
harrison gets head-butted and even
though he comes back to win the match he
doesn't stop and he intentionally breaks
the other wrestler's arm in front of
everyone dexter recognizes the pattern
here this is the second time he's done
something crazy violent but immediately
after it happens he's concerned that
kurt is right there things are obviously
weird between them now that he's seen
the kill room and dexter can't hide the
fact that he doesn't want him anywhere
near harrison they have words then they
have to leave and before dexter and
harrison can talk about what's really
going on he gets a call from angela who
has discovered iris's body in the cave
she tells him that she doesn't need gym
she needs dexter morgan and the episode
comes to an end so not only did a lot
happen we also moved closer to answers
about some of the things the show has
been asking us to think about harrison
is bothered by persistent violent
thoughts and if he continues to act out
people are going to notice kurt was so
obsessed with getting a replacement for
chloe that he admitted that he lied to
the police about the conversation with
matt and sending someone to use his
cards in new york obviously he was
hoping that she wouldn't be around to
tell anyone after he was finished but
now molly has some information that's
bad for him angela's finding iris is a
little puzzling at this point based on
what we've seen there's nothing that
looks similar to what's happening in
kurt's basement but i imagine her saying
she needs dexter morgan means she needs
his forensic skills perhaps he'll find
some connection or we'll learn that this
is not related and this is something
else he'll probably be shifting his
focus completely towards kurt and it
seems likely that harrison will be
pushed further in that direction in the
process why he's going out of his way to
get close to him is still up in the air
but i imagine that we're heading towards
open hostilities between curt and dexter
after the basement and the wrestling
match not to mention that dexter's thing
is killing serial killers one thing
about this episode was that it seemed to
confirm that harrison and molly's
motivations were sort of exactly what
they said they were molly came to iron
lake because she heard about matt going
missing and her presence might not be
connected to her having some secret
information and harrison tracked down
his dad because he wanted answers in
hopes that it might help him get past
his anger there's still a ton to
speculate on both of these characters
but i'll pick that up in the next video
when i put that out in a couple of days
there were some funny moments between
dexter thinking about the good old days
listening to the podcast and logan
saying you have no idea how many books
i've read about this when he asked him
how to patch things up with angela three
pretty heavy sequences dexter and angela
at the station with harrison at the
therapist and him confessing to audrey
then a few full-blown wtf moments with
kurt punching chloe's corpse angela
finding iris and harrison turning on
full psycho breaking mode in front of
everybody there's a lot of parallels
between the different stories here and
that sets up a situation where people
overlook things or they're not equipped
to handle things and there's a lot of
close calls of either people making
breakthroughs or getting what they need
that's all wrapped up in that it's kind
of a fun dynamic where we know that if
dexter said hey my mom was killed when i
was a kid right in front of me that they
could probably make progress in therapy
and i think that's a good place to leave
things let me know how you felt about
the episode in the comments let me know
what your theories are mine have shifted
a lot so definitely check back for my
follow-up video in a couple of days when
i think about this and leave a comment
and let me know what you're thinking
about please like this video if you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon